ne ferons pas face à autant de compétition.
Ils sont peut-être les véritables signes chanceux.
J'ai parcouru le palmarès Forbes
des 300 personnes les plus riches du monde,
et il est intéressant de constater
que les animaux les plus indésirables, le tigre et la chèvre,
sont en tête du palmarès,
devançant même le dragon.
Peut-être vaudrait-il mieux considérer
qu'il est plus favorable d'avoir moins de compétition.
Une dernière chose, tout aussi intéressante :
beaucoup de Chinois utilisent l'index du zodiaque chinois
pour prendre leurs décisions financières et d'investissements.
Même si les traditions et croyances du zodiaque chinois
remontent à des millénaires,
le choix de s'en soucier, pour prendre des décisions importantes,
est plus récent, et ne remonte qu'aux dernières décennies.
Nos ancêtres se préoccupaient davantage de leur survie
face à la pauvreté, à la sécheresse,
à la famine, aux émeutes, à la maladie ou aux guerres civiles.
Et maintenant, les Chinois ont enfin le temps,
les ressources financières et la technologie
pour créer la vie idéale, celle dont ils ont toujours rêvé.
Les décisions prises par une collectivité de 1,3 milliard de personnes
a eu une grande influence sur l'économie et la production de tous les biens,
que ce soit pour les soins médicaux, l'éducation,
l'immobilier ou les biens de consommation.
Étant donné que la Chine joue un rôle déterminant dans l'économie
et la géopolitique de notre monde,
les décisions basées sur le zodiaque chinois
et sur d'autres traditions chinoises,
finissent par influencer grandement l'ensemble de la planète.
Y a-t-il des singes dans la salle ?
2016 est l'année du singe.
Les singes sont intelligents,
curieux,
créatifs,
et espiègles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)